If you're a member, we talked about
resource qualifiers in lesson one.
The idea's that you can vary
things like drawables, strings,
even layouts based on qualifiers like
language and device orientation.
There are a number of resource
qualifiers you can use to start changing
your UI based on screen size.
The primary ones you should use are
width, height, landscape orientation.
And portrait orientation.
Width and height simply mean
the device's current width or height.
Which of course changes when you rotate
the device to portrait or landscape.
There's is also the smallest
width qualifier.
Which is the smaller of
the screen's width or height.
It's the same in either portrait or
landscape, so
it's a useful qualifier for
controlling attributes that you
don't want to vary when you rotate
the device, such as font sizes.
There's also small, normal, large,
and extra large size buckets.
These are less useful and because
they don't give you as much control.
They're considered deprecated.
So going back to break points, say we
chose a break point point of 600 dps.
Once the screen is wider than 600 dps,
we want to tweak our UI.
For this,
we add the w600dp directory qualifier to
hold whatever new resources we create.
Another good resource to use
is the design metrics tool
on the Google design website.
It lists the screen dimensions and
densities for
many popular devices in Android,
iOS, ChromeOS and
Android Wear, along with a UI
designer in Android Studio.
It's a good way to visualize how
your design might need to change to
fill up space on, say,
a Nexus 9 in landscape mode.